In addition to AI problems having several characteristics,
AI agents too have several properties. Property number one. AI agents,
have only a limited computing power, processing speed, memory size, and
so on. Property number two. AI agents have limited sensors,
they cannot perceive everything in the world. Property number three.
AI agents have limited attention, they cannot focus on everything at the same
time. Property number four. Computational logic is fundamentally deductive.
Property number five. The world is large, but AI agents' knowledge of the world
is incomplete relative to the world. So, the question then becomes, how can AI
agents with such bounded rationality address open-ended problems in the world?